feminist gut reaction is that they must
be paid differently because of gender
well maybe it's because you're just
Dumber maybe you don't offer as good of
commentary maybe you're not as well
known there are many reasons why one
person gets paid and another doesn't as
someone that runs a show that actually
thinks these things through I might know
that person a will bring me 10,000
viewers and person B will bring me 2,000
viewers there are some people that get
more value just by coming on the show
then the show gets from them and what
modern women do is they and they
cry and they moan later instead of just
negotiating better and working harder